هذا النهر الجليدي المذهل الواقع في
ألاسكا هو وجهة سياحية شهيرة
ولكن أفضل طريقة لرؤيته هي من
داخل
نهر ميندنهال الجليدي هو نهر جليدي يبلغ طوله 12 ميلاً
في وادي
ميندينهال في غابة تونغاس الوطنية في ألاسكا ،
الكهوف الجليدية هي الأنهار الجليدية التي يمكن
الوصول إليها من الداخل.  هذه الجدران الجليدية متاحة فقط
للمغامرين حقًا
لرؤية الكهوف الجليدية تتطلب رحلة بقوارب الكاياك
وتسلق الجليد فوق النهر الجليدي
وبمجرد أن تصبح مؤمنًا بأن الجدران الذائبة من
حولك لن تتخلى عنها ولكن
هذه الأعجوبة الطبيعية تحت  التهديد الذي كان
النهر الجليدي يتعامل معه بسرعة لا تصدق
في السنوات الأخيرة بسبب
ارتفاع درجات الحرارة وارتفاع مستويات سطح البحر ،
فقد انحسر بما يقرب من ميلين منذ عام 1958
ولكن ما تبقى هو
فانتازيلاند المذهلة تمامًا
[موسيقى]
أنت